what's going on guys welcome to another
python mathematics and stock indicators
tutorial video
this video we're going to be talking
about the shake and money flow uh the
shaken money flows
intention is to measure money flow into
and out of a stock it's created by uh mr
mark
jacob and it acts as an oscillator and
oscillates above and below
a zero line the calculation of the
shaken money flow
is in three steps basically it's going
to be
closed minus the low minus the high
minus the close
divided by the high minus low then the
next step is going to be to take
step one otherwise known as the money
flow multiplier and
multiply that by the time frame's
period total volume
so the time frame periods total volume
sorry i couldn't get that quite out
step three would be to take uh that time
frame
sum of step two which is known as the
money flow volume
and divide that by that time frame's
period's total volume
so let's look at a couple examples here
i'll bring up the charting
application that we'll be working on and
let's look at apple
so here is apple the shake and money
flow is the
bottom indicator there and as you can
see it oscillates here's the zero line
it's oscillating up and down but
um one of the more useful things that
you can do is
actually make it make the zero line and
then fill above and below that line with
a colored fill
so let me show you an example of with a
colored fill
so let's look at apple again
and this time we can obviously see apple
with a nice
colored fill so the idea is to show you
when money is either entering the stock
or when money has been leaving the stock
so
even here you can see that it's really
strong it's pretty strong but it's
weakening it's continues to weaken and
it gets pretty weak here
though it continues uh obviously holding
up some sort of money because it
continues going up but then you can see
as it crashes down here
we can see really that money is leaving
this stock uh
pretty solidly so we can look at another
one we can check out maybe amazon
so here's a good one where it continues
rising and you can just see
where you know especially here too and
then here where a lot of money
um is at least shown to have possibly
entered the stock
and then all through here i mean this
would be a really really strong
shaking indicator here showing just pure
growth so
pretty interesting so
uh that's some examples of the shake and
money flow
um oscillator here now in the next video
we're actually going to be working out
how to calculate this within python and
then the subsequent video after that
we'll actually chart it up
just like this we'll chart it on this
chart so anyway stay tuned for those
videos as always thanks for watching
thanks for the support and subscriptions
and until next time